finally freedom for them and their
families exonerates it but only after
serving 36 years for a murder they
didn't commit and look for with men
living the rest of my life being humble
as peaceful as I am praising God looking
out for my family
oh man I'm telling you it's out of this
world we all sat in walls but in the
inside I hate to put it like this we
went through hell and what needs to see
us out here we smiling can happy they'll
be free but we got a lot to fix I really
don't have the words to say I just think
this is real this is first time I have
been able to hug my son in about 20-some
years this is wonderful
in 1984 and they were teenagers
Alfred Chestnut Andrew Stewart and
ransom Watkins were sentenced to life
for killing 14 year-old Jewett Duquette
at a Harlem Park school but Alfred got
the case reopened uncovering evidence
that was ignored and withheld he worked
with the University of Baltimore
Innocence Project what is particularly
striking about this case however it was
the cascade of institutional failures
for lack of a better way of expressing
it I mean there was problems with
eyewitness identification but this was
not your typical mistaken eyewitness
identification this was this had to do
with a you know essentially police and
apparently prosecutorial misconduct they
were locked up despite the fact multiple
witnesses identified another person as
the killer
the three men spent 12 years together at
Maryland penitentiary ransom Watkins
said of their time here we held on to
each other that's what got us through
they spent another two decades behind
bars but apart losing family members
while inside
they must now try to move on in a
community where they were ostracized and
imprisoned they really are three very
remarkable men I think you could just
see from yesterday the way that they
carried themselves the way they speak
the kind of dignity that they exude
which I'm sure has been forged through
you know literally decades of enduring
immense suffering and remaining hopeful
they may well try to pursue compensation
but it's the immediate challenges they
must wrestle with adjusting to life on
the outside
Cordelia Lynch Sky News Baltimore